hi everybody and welcome to today's live
broadcast which is called figured by two
gels real-world use of lunch at
microfluidic technology for nucleic acid
and protein analysis my name's Paul
Butler of perkinelmer and I'll be
moderating today's event and today's
webcast is presented by lab roots calm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and it's sponsored
by PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
they have a dedicated team of seven
thousand seven hundred employees
worldwide who are passionate about
providing customers with an unmatched
experience as they help solve critical
issues in human and environmental health
their innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with deep market knowledge and
expertise help customers gain greater
insights into their science to better
protect our environment food supply and
the health of our families you can see /
can almost website at www cannell marcom
in today's web seminar scientists will
present on their experiences in
converting from acrylamide and sds-page
gel separation asses to microfluidic or
lab on a chip technology lab on a chip
technologies have been around for around
a decade and have been adopted as
industry standards particularly in the
biotech and pharma environment the
largest community performing nucleic
acid and protein separation as however
the academic research community and
mostly they are running traditional gel
methods the goal of today's session is
to demystify this area for everyone
including the academic researchers about
the alternatives available and the
possible vent benefits
they can bring before we start there are
a few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to if you
would like and you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type in your comments and questions
we will try to get as to as many as we
can and we will follow up if we don't
have time today if you like a better
look you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
and if you can't hear or see the
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button and
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues the webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits and if
you click on the c/e button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits but now
let's get right to the end to today's
presentations we are proud to welcome
Sandra Doran dr. Julius Carsten and
Veronica del chivo starting with
sunderland Sandra Doran as a medical
scientist for path West clinical
immunology at the funeral san lee
hospital and Perth in Western Australia
HLA typing is a large component of the
work performed by clinical immunology
primarily for solid organ and bone
marrow transplantation the majority of
her experience and miss Department has
involved working with the molecular
based HLA typing us is originally this
involved Sanger sequence B typing
methods and more recently she has been
heavily involved in the implementation
of next-generation sequencing using life
technologies I in turn platform so with
that I'm going to hand over to a de
sandra and thank you very much for
talking today Sandra especially as
you're based in the Western Australia
and it's ten o'clock at night or after
that so I'm so thanks again and over to
you Sandra thankful and good morning
every everybody and as I
Paul has this indicated I am I'm with
the Department of Clinical Immunology in
Perth Western Australia at the new that
opened in the last two years Fiona
Stanley Hospital so at clinical
immunology we the main test we have we
have an inning of solid each section
where we look after HIV viral load and
quantity on TV essays we also have a
section involved with autoimmunity doing
immunofluorescence safe SI for auto
antibodies we have serology based typing
for our solid organ donation program and
as Paul mentioned molecular base typing
where the majority of that is a chelate
we do transplantation and non
transplantation genetics in this team so
it is a quick background the majority of
our work is related to donor a patient
of solid organ and bone marrow
transplantation the deeds of interest
are located on chromosome 6 in the major
histocompatibility complex and includes
enclose the histocompatibility leukocyte
antigen so hateful a molecules these
molecules are important in the
regulation of the immune system and
present antigenic peptides the t-cells
the HLA genes are known to be the most
pointless exchange system in humans when
most of the polymorphism is combined the
peptide through binding groove of the
molecule hate to lay a BC drb1 the QB 1
and D pv1 our genes known to be most
important to transplantation so I'm
previously for sonar sequence-based
typing applications and the region of
interest would be amplified and then run
on a gel prior prior to purification
through various PCR reactions so rather
than running everything every sample
potentially nicely up to 96 on anyone
run only positive and negative control
to determine the relative validity of
the essays along with any other samples
were gels so edges samples we build
simply to speed up any repeat processes
that were required so we've known at
that stage before sequencing
that sample required repeating so while
some users find running gels or
therapeutic part of their day there are
definitely times when it can become
painful so if the girl results are not
quantitative these are some of the
limitations and at least five
microliters of our pcr product pre
purification is required if this is if
it means repeating it can obviously take
into your sample volume and it can fill
out any answer the sample ratio of
purification it also does not account
for any other errors errors that may
occur at purification as all samples
were not filled sales samples will often
sequence and this causes downstream
unnecessary reagent yes of course there
is also the disadvantage of using
expedia umbrellas even though than most
minimal amount possible reviews there's
still an exposure risk the equipment is
also bulky and requires maintenance and
in our department a whole room is
dedicated to gel electrophoresis and the
daily cleaning requirements were never
popular amongst us lastly there's also
the menu nature of running the jealous
like any moment ass there is risk in
repetition the risk of sample mix up in
the manual transfer and there is
definitely a risk of getting busy with
another task and letting a gel run off
and of course dropping me or gel or two
was never unheard of so while changing
to another system would eliminate these
limitations and our major reasons the
changing was the swap to next-generation
sequencing and it required a
quantitative and qualitative instruments
so it's going to a quick overview of the
time to NGS and our new work point and
where the love keeps 15 so firstly we
conduct the PCR of the hopefully a b c d
r b1 b2 b1 and DP v 1 pcr these are
currently at six different assays and
the same samples are reacted in the same
position across the six separate place
we then want to take every sample we
need to know that each pcr post
purification is has
successful we then called with fixed
volume in a laboratory currently and any
space battles from the PCR reaction are
removed at this step to prevent
sequencing downstream and major cost
benefit of that we then prepare our
libraries and just quickly this involves
fearing of Africana products to about
400 to 500 base pairs we then like gates
our fragments with p1 is after at one
end and a specific barcode to announce
that enable sample cooling and the other
end of the fragrance our libraries are
then quantitative again this is to
determine the concentration of our five
hundreds of base by 400 500 base pair
regions we have in normalizing our
libraries and pulling an interception so
we pulled six samples into one tube and
then we side select on an eagle our
fragments are collected and then
amplified using primers that that bind
to our barcode and RP one adapter we
then quantitate a third time in the
process services our sample pools we
quantitate sample pool so we can then
normalize which is very important for
our sequencing steps through the
emulsion PCR the enrichment and then
finally the sequencing so the lab 50x
plays an important role at three
different steps our answer Quan
computation our library quantitation and
our final size selected cool
quantitation so first our pcr product
quantitation on the lab test our become
the now amplified purified and land
market this enables us to eliminate any
failures as I previously mentioned which
is a huge downstream cost savings the
current method for an amplicon polling
is speaks volumes so we we have done
various experiments to determine the
best volume however we haven't ruled out
down further down the line from
normalizing our PCR products so we will
be able to use stored information that
we've got from the lab tip and obviously
that quan
patient data will help us able to
normalize our products our pcr data can
also now be efficiently stored as the
sort of the world that tip file which we
can easily just pull back up into the
software and and really look at our the
quality of our products on at a certain
time and it's also stored in our
database for troubleshooting purposes
when if there's failures or at any point
we can look back into that sample one
and try and troubleshoot where where
things with me so we use the high
sensitivity assays for our library
quantitation at two different stages and
first the visual check is performed to
determine that our current enzymatic
sharing reaction is performing
accurately and it's not under all over
Syrian cities after you've got here is
quite a nice neat flat curve I'm just
eaten so we've got this knife unmeet
curve yeah and the software then enables
us if you can see the red line this red
line this region we can quantitate that
class really so it's a bit more maybe
for you to see that 400 base pair along
the scale is here 500 here and the
software enables us to make a smear of
that region and quantitate that
accurately we are also able to check our
our location location step and monitor
any our purification as well as you can
see any prime Adama that may be
appearing in our product and also at
this step we are able to eliminate any
sales samples to prevent them in going
any further and repeat them at the stage
they require and again all of our
samples are tracked through the database
Ross there on the lab chip and then all
the information goes back into our
database when we've got that information
at the other side it also has no manual
transfer of samples is required if any
of the steps and only one microliter is
used by the lab tip so if this precious
Apple we only have
Micah leaders at these stages and so
taking five microliters out for a bill
is not ideal okay so moving on to how we
actually went about implementing the lab
tip into our laboratories so if the
electric underwent an extensive
validation process you file
implementation this is particularly
important for the 5k essay as it was to
replace our gel electrophoresis for all
Sanger sequencing assays as well as play
the important role in our NGS workflow
so to be implemented the lab chip 5 que
si had to meet our acceptable criteria
for reproducibility sensitivity and
sequence quality first reproducibility
so expected sizes for each essay were
determined and variation in migration
between the lab tip and ammonium gel
electrophoresis was observed so to
determine the new effective peak sizes
95 samples for each locus though some
pics were overlaid the software was then
used to confirm what the new page size
was and that it was reproducible within
a window of ten cent all peaks were then
identified by the software indicating
that they was reproducible so if I hate
to lay a for example our expected pieces
now 3400 bases and at the bottom of
throughout GPB to 10 saves 5700 places
we also don't need to look at within
running reproducibility we're 15 samples
from one run overlaid and then the
software was used to to determine
whether they were in within ten percent
of each other using our our new sizes
that we had determined we then look at
the tween run reproducibility where we
used our internal control across five
separate PCR reactions again for every
lotus and use the software tool to
determine if those peeps were within ten
cent of same size of each other I have a
few examples for you so are we being run
I've got a class one
hey chill absa is a top window our
estimate our new science was three
thousand base pairs but overlay to fight
for fifteen samples from one run on top
of each other you can see that they're
very neatly placed along on top of each
other and here with the upper market at
seven thousand base pairs we can also
see which would which would sometimes be
a blur on a gel that we have got some
background or other segments that aren't
assigned quite as well a second example
which is nice and clean without DPS a
this is our largest essay as 5,700 base
pairs so it fits quite close to the
upper marker and but you can also see
that all the peeps are really nicely
overlaid on from one another and one of
one of the advantages of the software is
we can type in our page size of 5700
makes the windows ten percent press go
and it will tell you all of the samples
that have a pitfall within within that
range and services are for all 15 of our
peak speed so just quickly again with
between run I've got a hateful a a plus
one essay so our HSA size 3400 fee and
since the peak they always believed
nicely business the same sample run on
five different reactions and then care
for class to drb1 at 3,400 we can see
our lpg a-- it's five different
reactions begin hence the differences in
concentration but this picture does
quite clearly show that whilst the PCR
reactions the difference be peach size
across each run remains the same when
run on the last ship so it's a pass and
sensitivity the lab tips must be as
sensitive as our gel electrophoresis in
one hundred percent of samples so if we
had a positive joe sample we decided
that the mud pit must pick that up
positive for it to go on to sequencing
and and we set that rate at a hundred
percent our current scoring system was
um going of one two three and four
dependent on gel intensity and the
reader would score
score there y'all teachers our routine
criteria was that a gel score through or
above with then move on to downstream
sequencing processes so we needed to
work out a lab tip concentration that
that was a cut off value and compare our
girls schools to what we were getting on
the lab tip to ensure that we were were
sending the right Apple's through to
sequencing so across the 95 samples of
the six pcr that we ran on the lab
supplies que si we also run every sample
by gel electrophoresis then an
insensitivity plots by plotting the gels
ball against the concentration on the
last tip so we've got feed girls gone
and the does the why yes so we've got
the gel score along Y axis and then the
lab chip concentration across the X so
from a from our results all of our
negative control samples there was one
on every run how to field scored zero
and a lab chip concentration range in
between zero and zero point two
nanograms per microliter so you can see
that they're these samples at six in the
bottom corner of each of each essay
generally speaking observation remains
that our concentration of 1.5 nanograms
per microliter or greater on the lab
tech correlated with a gel score 2 or
above in all of the samples run only one
dps Apple did not obtain a logic
concentration and we had a dull scorer
for this was retrospectively accounted
for by the sorry running the sample and
then and then it fell back into line and
had a concentration so the data
therefore shows a hundred percent of
samples with a positive gel bands are
successfully quantitated by the lunch
shift yet next we have to look at
sequence quality and the validation
criteria subsequence quality wasn't met
when we have greater than ninety percent
of our samples with a gel score of true
or greater meeting our sequence quality
acceptance and we looked at to determine
a suitable cut off point for our essays
for our so a short-range essays the
sequence quality for the sample with the
lowest lab tip concentration was
evaluated as sang a sequence products
are analyzed using a sign software the
signal strength and base called scores
are used as a measure of quality control
in the table it shows that the sample
cell within an acceptable range and
could successfully be analyzed and
reporters for even a laboratory it was
decided its concentration cut off the
leaves and phases be set as 0.3
nanograms per microliter this is
slightly higher than our BP wel of 0.27
and it's slightly lower than our other
values of 0.41 nanograms per microliter
just a reminder business a lot of
concentration has achieved from the
largest we've now been using the cutoff
from 0.3 nanograms per meter for over 12
months and we haven't noticed a
increased failure rate for those essays
where it was a little bit higher-end
0.41 so just for ease we said that
cutoff for those classes at that same
value to determine the cutoff for our
NGS and samples a sensitivity attached
the nexus was done and every sample with
sequence to find next-generation
sequencing samples that met our sequence
criteria and obtained the correct
steampipe address on this type of having
our results so these samples at did work
others asses involute for each separate
essay samples they do not meet our
sequencing criteria or did not obtain
the correct in part were grafted having
no result and these are the ones in red
so so hatefully a b c d and e to the a
poster the majority of successful self
is held pcr concentration of greater
than one milligram per month earlier
this is especially clear in the a so at
one known as
the lines yes all thousands that works
in pain the random attack had a
concentration of greater than one and
all samples that failed higher
concentration and of less than one this
was was the make majority of the case
for all the essays accepted lead PB one
where the concentration of 0.5
milligrams per microliter which is here
an example with the concentration lower
than that failed sequencing so that is
where we said our cutoff there were a
few outliers with any essay that did
work color there are lots of other steps
involved in the sequence in the process
so they could be accountable for
different reasons and Swami set the
concentration of one milligram per
microliter for all that phase and 0.5
for our DTV one so just quickly
validating the high sensitivity FA and
comparisons were performed between the
lab tech high sensitivity SI and the
Agilent fire analyzer and the qubit they
all had variations in in their values
and differences between every instrument
was observed a decision to go to the lab
to TX was because of the high platform
we have the ability to run a 96-well
plate and we also could easily
interchange it with the 5k SI which
would in turn obviously replace our bill
electrophoresis for our pcr applicants
and once the instrument is required
sequencing runs will optimize using the
concentrations and sliding data provided
by the lightship so for this purpose we
we got the instrument first and then we
worked up our ass sequencing steps using
the data that's that the instrument gave
us an optimized from there so in
conclusion alpha que si is a sensitive
as dielectrophoresis in a hundred
percent of the samples it was
reproducibility ability within ten
percent was met for all samples and our
cutoff values as i mentioned were one
milligram
malia for our long-range essays except
proud be better once the largest essay
and that is cut off has is 0.5
milligrams per microliter we also been
determined a 0.3 nanogram per microliter
for a short range a phase I'll saying a
sequence based I penises our high
sensitivity assay is appropriate for our
post pcr and NGS quantitation
requirements so the locket was
validation was completed and we
implemented it into a routine website on
the twenty-third of December last year
so it is quickly the larger impact on
immunology so only small quantities of
gels are now made we potentially run one
gel 114 Lane gel per fortnight just for
the smaller things that we haven't been
validated for the lab tip so the vast
expanses of gels are no longer made and
readers no longer have to score the fuel
pictures with eliminated variation in
results often greases or inconsistencies
in the lab chip results can be corrected
in the software without having to rerun
the sample which is really user-friendly
and samples can be tracked while being
run on the instrument and the data can
be directly imported back into our
database which is is a huge bonus from
the instrument and we used it for
everyone so overall the lab chip does
save us time body and yes purposes the
pcr quantitation step has actually
increased in time and business due to
the lab tip itself but it just due to
the to the new workflow and and typing
speaks amplicons for every sample so a
96-well plate takes an hour to run on
the lab tips tons of us fix that six
hours of quantitation which is quite
timely however if you think of running
696 Lane girls yes it's not really so
bad so to help overcome this we have
just recently validated and implemented
a second allowed 50x touch instrument
into the lab and it has effectively cut
this time in half the second instrument
also helps to alleviate the cues that
were forming with everyone needing to
get on the instrument
for one time and also provide us
redundancy because even 12 months on
without the lab she found our workflow
essentially has to wait the ability to
quantitate our pre and post and pure
products has also highlighted
deficiencies in other aspects of our
work for such as our am pure recovery so
if the instrument is helping us to
further refine and optimize essays that
even though we had been performing for
for a long period of time and it's
information that we didn't have before
and we're using that information to
further optimize to murphys essay and
that is all I happy today so thank you
very much thanks under that was a great
presentation and I'm sure that there
might be some questions at the end for
you there as well so with help from from
Sandra who's a scientist working in the
sort of clinical Diagnostics area and
who's converted from using gels for
nucleic acids and when they're going to
hear from an academic scientist and who
has previously it was converted to using
mike's poetic technology for protein
analysis and dr. julius Causton received
his PhD in molecular biology from the
University of Vienna and he worked on
protein protein interactions of
cytoskeletal associated proteins within
the group of gerhard fish at the mfp l
and Vienna eight years ago julius joined
the group of christina Janovich kiragu
also at the MS PL in Vienna with the
main focus on protein crystallography
biophysical and biochemical
characterization of proteins and protein
complexes protein purification and
structural biology of f-actin based
cytoskeleton during the last three years
he worked as a staff scientist in the
lower Abbas a center for optimized
structural studies and also known as the
coss which is a collaborative research
project coordinated by M Christina
Janovich Carew go
the main interest of the USS is the
research of innovative methods for
production of sufficient quantities of
high quality and functionally active
proteins for structural and functional
analysis nowadays focusing mainly on the
production and structure determination
of protein complexes involving proteins
of the Z desk interactome so and so
Julius with that I'm going to hand over
to you and vote for your great
presentation thank you very much hello
everyone okay my title I just call it a
chips and lab chips how does it taste
it's like more general overview or four
for lab chip and I think the main
question that's what is there it onto
the page whether it can really somehow
resemble or just just replace as these
pages we know it and I think this is
just going through it so it's our
experience we gained in one year of
usage it and and with the further do I
just quickly summarize portable to polar
they said I mean um from the cause which
is really a center of ultimate
structural studies it's a it's a
consists of two companies and free
economic partners some people which you
might know and of course it's come
during coordinated by our group leader
or my OPI PCR which cargo and the main
interest again which we which we are
doing its focusing on protein in this
case you can see it can produce the
protein PFI crystallized and what is
very easy today is to do which of course
you have quite an access to facilities
solve some of the problems electricity
structures there's still the main main
bottleneck in all this it's just really
gain the proteins and and get crystals
so this is what we are trying to
actually somehow solve and I'm focus on
these bottlenecks as possibly are
looking at the studies protein so only
that she just know what it is is it not
to scare you with too many things but
one can look at this this kind of
line which is which is here which is
called as a disc and it's very important
for the muscle function and when we
won't look at what's inside there is
really a huge amount of proteins which
you which you can find out that they
interact and we would like to really try
to fill find them isolate them anyway
see how they interact in the free
dimension space so is it really lots of
work to do and one way of course
nowadays how it is it to its to try to
ultimate ines lots of fruit is use
advantage of the robotics so in our case
we are able to be found a pelican large
scale using some actor pews and so on we
have some some machines they're doing
lots of buffers and screens and of
course machines that I'm able to run for
us it's mostly purification screens or
interaction essays and these actually
led to producing of lots of data which
need to be analyzed and quantified and
at one point be trying to ask them in
how we are going to do that so and we
will put for us some criteria which you
uses as a select instrument that is able
to do it and this criteria temples just
we would like at that time to persist
fast and there'll be some from 1 to
1,000 samples probably even more to get
some simplification especially
quantification are having an and
conversion of the data you would like to
have a someone provides reasonable price
is probably establishing the feel and is
there support is always important and
definitely wanted to reduce the town was
working this mr. machine and an amount
of the sample one on maybe need for
round we compute several instruments at
that time and I think one of the best in
which came was was lab chip which we are
talking today about and I think was
really really one of the good ones if
one look at that we really do only
protein chips in this case although
although there is a possibility and
thunder was mentioning that it's
possible to do it when the DNA but how
it is rnase but for essays which which
are provided by perkinelmer there are
several so instead of protein you can
have a let's say free a fart it for
protein we just don't do the charge
variants or glycol screening you can you
can see here but we focus mainly only on
the low molecular weight or a protein
express ship the reason is for that that
the unfortunately they have a lower
sensitivity than the pic of protein but
whatever I really do is that one with
other HTML similar to the Pico you cook
your sample in the presence of some
fluorescent dye which usually bonds to
license that's a little bit not good for
us because then you're depending on the
sequence of the of your protein and
suddenly you might not if you have a
protein we should have a veritable lower
amount of lysine or not able to see it
why I think the only instrument which is
I think getting on the moment on market
which use the protein Express and all
molecular weight cheap there you do
labeling nicely any flags I just go
further you can see you can you're doing
it on the chip if you look at how it
looks like dancing and you're using
fluorescently labeled SDS which is
really great because they were
independent on the sequence and and
that's very important if you work with a
variety of proteins so what is nice be
standing in the staining it allows you
that it really fast lee fast to see the
result and I mean what you can still see
on on the chips and that that that just
going going quickly here I mean here is
written the time after how much you need
probably to run one sample it's in a
minute so 96-well plate one is possible
to check and analyze it is in one hour
and that's something what we together
with the standing there staining
something but you don't get in a normal
life is sds-page so with this respect I
would go quickly to the software and
that's 11 expect one into always trying
to look at it when you buy machine and
you would like to run it you have
something in an innocent simple to start
it on student coming there and not think
about okay I there's a huge manual which
you need to again learn and know what
it's going on so I would say it's very
easy
and into it the way of finding which
which were layer but it well you would
like to select inspect and what is very
important as why you while you're
running it you can see the
electropherogram because that's what
you're measuring is a fluorescent and
actually what you what you can see you
can see virtual gel so you see actually
the results online coming back to to
finish I mean as I say it's easy start
and easy finish what is what I really
like it that you can have several plates
there several rounds and you can you can
really see except of electropherogram at
the virtual gel this is shown here you
can look at that senior band but the
other things which you're getting is
lots of lots of difficult to see
probably but lots of outcomes so like
the size of the protein concentration of
the protein purity H and really many
things that can very easily to be done
export actually from from interface
either in the sense of the of the
pictures jpegs PNG's and so on or
different formats that can be really
then transferring to excels and envy
shown and graph way so going into into
real life here I just would like to drag
your attention to two at the moment this
this part where you can see we load it
different amount of the samples going
down and you have you have here the gel
comparison of that and not exactly that
almost the same thing what you are able
to see with the gel is really when you
run it it's like molex you staying in
this thing you you you you really have
finally someone like a fixed fixed
picture with the SDS page and to really
generate this feature you you I needed
to load in this case I most and what
market of the samples at the lab chip
here you think this is to marketers a
sample and only small amounts and not
only just were used to do that and the
other thing you have this dynamic range
so if won't go further you can you can
start to play with
the contrast and so on and you start to
see bands which were not possible to see
to get different picture and especially
have really much broader dynamic range
when you're assessing the concentrations
of the proteins and this is well I think
big big blast going further unless you
play too much so other things it's a
resolution again for your attention
Church from one could try to look at
this last two lines you have an sds-page
where I mean gel was crowding jealous
commercial one you got the smiley things
there and we let it run be longer
because you wanted to see other things
as well you start to have this fountain
s there and you're asking is this really
is this really a part of the author of
the of the protein or there are two
separate spent if you run the lab chip
and you can compare this two lines to
this one it clearly see that you have
this resolution and suddenly you you
seem much more than before so a lot of
important many times to know what you're
looking for at but it really gives you
very high contrast and resolution
comparison to Chris Diaz page gels in
what it also does when you do I say so
until now probably won't think about do
I mean on the gel ten ten ten samples
having having logic allows you to really
go through not 110 but fifty or hundred
samples and you can start to look at the
things different way so for example this
experiment which was done here is the
kind of binding assay within running it
and preparing the samples up to getting
getting quantification and see maybe
reach of these buffers are important and
unimportant for interaction in our case
is it just took like two hours with all
these okay menu and so on really so it
really gives you different thinking of
it and instead of like looking really
small and running your purification and
really says try to squeeze amount of the
samples that case it you have 15 15
motel you can go and for certain more
and finally it brings you the quality in
your life as because you you can really
look at the same differently in a kind
of compare
after the lab or a gel to live cheap
comparison what you can see this was the
essay which we done whether was
increasing the amount of protein and our
you can still there is a transition so
there was a binding which we were able
to measure and we did this experiment
free time so it was free independent
essays and we stained distinct gels
kanden des metrically and try to assess
the values which we're here and try to
reconsider it and make a binding curve
and we did the same with the with the
lab chip so you can see the same same
samples we were run on the lab tube and
we try to compare how the bounding
curves is going to look like and if you
if you see the photo for the lab chip as
well for the gel there is it really fair
let's say compromiser there really a
very enough in the innocence that almost
similar sometimes you can see even for
the lab chip that you have higher
aerobars you're coming there mostly it's
probably the human aerial money to take
an accountant there is really stupid i
think some sample there although with
multi-channel purposes and so on but
this this can come there and look it
could be variations which are coming it
but really it's very fair enough example
these nice positive features and it's
try to renal regular attention a little
bit to something mods what wanted to
face with the logic and this is
different migration of the protein on
the on the lab chip than on a gel and
example of that I wanted to show you on
this this gel which you look at it we
had the protein which is called acting
and we supposed to hear my credit 42
kilo dalton which is on this page clear
and another protein which I calls XY
said it should be around 22 kilo dalton
and migrated here if we go back and look
at that word is spreading my grades and
what's the estimate of molecular weight
on the on from the lab chip you can see
the acting comes with 48 and sit wise
with 28 kill daughter this is not
surprised I think perkinelmer it's
telling you that yeah there is a plus
minus twenty percent error on the
estimates after of the molecular a
comparison
and what it should be but sometimes this
is a problem especially when you go for
more complex samples so here this
picture was not made by by lab chip but
with some other and i would like to drag
your attention to the line number 15
where you can what you can see it's
relatively complex sample and here we
were looking at the somehow kind of
expression so this is the expression
screen which partially p find the sample
and if you are looking for the strongest
band you will expect this is my protein
but what you if you don't have any other
discriminant normally what you are using
it's a molecule wait molecular weight
will tell you okay this is where you
need to need to look at it and if your
molecular weight it's not exact and it's
just really shifted up and now it's
really difficult somehow to catch what's
going on there and that's a little bit i
think disadvantage of the author of the
lab chip so there are still some other
ones so except of detonation molecular
mass i will say that there is
flexibility so in sa running of the
really small amount of samples at the
moment still I think a little bit
expensive and the number which i call it
reasonable will be maybe twenty up to 50
samples per day so stability of the
reagent when you when you really find
the chiefs and have a cheap ready
usually it's roughly eight hours so this
is window in which you can do the things
and round the things which is a grantee
/ perky linemen and we know that
sometimes this is not enough especially
we have some people were working longer
and and do this it's a little bit
robustness because I you will probably
would like to have a dedicated person
that is able to handle a little bit the
chip and inhuman machine because if
something breaks you you lose the chip
which caused me I mean really quite it's
more expensive than than one gels which
will be broken by my um some student
just just by chance and there is the
cause of the instruments versus
conventional egg prefer is still a
little bit higher for for a scientific
community it's always a question how it
with the publishing and and out
return how they will be accepted by
reviewers and the people because it's it
I'm not like the machine is founded in a
different way of reading actually the
gels as we know it now because you have
this resolution you start to see more
more things and then you need Morris
dedicated reagent in in a sense to be
able to run that in the conclusions i
would say the lab is really different
way of looking at this protein be any
separation alice's a quality fish as we
know it and and and it's really good
asking for routine establish high and
medium fluid analysis and really what it
brings except of the speed accuracy
actually automation finally simplicity
and especially as well the safety you
don't have to really have this a tedium
bromine acrylamide and all this stuff
it's a it's a different thinking into
into the process because suddenly you
can you can really go and try to run
more samples and then to see more and
it's really big benefit the question
still remains for me and probably okay
whether it that you can reply is
classically sds-page what of course it
cannot be kissed the ready speech you
will still probably use whether you want
to run the Western blood whether you
want to link cut the bands and send it
for mass spectroscopy or so so more and
more appropriate will be whether it
became can become a standard in each lab
and to have it and i think yes it's
possible here I always just suggest few
things but say that for most procurement
but most were thinking one can imagine
if there with the chips which are really
prepared and you just the plaque and
place it is like a precast gel which you
put in and everyone can you run it it
will be very great the same if you can
prolong class time of the chip and that
that alarms you really much broader
window and anyone can come in any time
of the day and use it what will be
really good to have maybe different
markers that can really help to really s
criminate the molecular mass the option
is to use really pack a specific time
featuring nowadays on the market
and can maybe then increase the
application Reggie sensitivity and could
be similar to the West imploding okay
lowering the price of the instrument as
I say you you you buy a cheaper
instrument and then you will probably be
very addicted to that we will king of
buying lots of chips and around as much
as possible or to have a more universal
shells may be disposable chips that that
are just really used for 10 samples and
throw it away what would be really nice
if the software although it's very
simple and easy really with this amount
of that you're obtaining then get some
kind of work like a database as well
more in this direction so I say how does
it taste for me i would say for me it
stays very good and for for all other
ones I think we are there I would say
you need to taste it thanks for your
attention okay okay it's like yeah
thanks Julius a nice presentation very
balanced so am for our final
presentation Saturday with help from a
clinical scientist use converted from
gels for nucleic acids we've heard from
Julius as an academic scientist has
converted to lab chip for protein from
agile approach or certainly and moved
away from generals and i think is fair
to say and one of the questions that
people listening today might have is how
does the these new technologies actually
work and you may have some other
questors as well so i'm going to in a
second introduce her final presentation
from veronica del chiva and which will
hopefully answer those questions so I'm
Veronica delchev aunt is a fueled
application scientist with perkinelmer
since December 2012 together with 15
she's responsible for pre and post-sales
projects covering the the microphone
Ock's
also known as lab chip product portfolio
in Europe she has a diploma in
engineering and which is equivalent to
an MSC and it's a biotechnology degree
from the university of applied sciences
in darmstadt in germany prior to joining
perkin-elmer veronica was a scientific
employee at the molecular genetic
laboratory of the psychiatric
psychosomatic and psychotherapeutic
clinic of the infantile an adolescent
age the university clinic in frankfurt
are mine where she participated in
projects related to the research of the
risk factor for autistic spectrum
disorders so with that I'm going to hand
over to Veronica for the final
presentation of the day thank you Paul
first of all welcome to the last
presentation of the today's webinar my
part of the session will be dedicated to
the lab ship microfluidics technology
and how it can replace lap gels for the
nucleic acids in the protein
characterization we will go through a
quick overview about the runs at the
first after short and direct
introduction which would include the
chip preparation in the video and the
sample preparation part afterwards it
make sense to share your video about how
the chip which have itself works and on
one of the last slides I will present
some screenshots of the software be
showing you t of the interesting tools
of the software analysis options so one
of the questions which you might have
already asked yourself especially when
you're here today has how can get rid of
this slab shells so if I would modify
this question bit it would sound like
how can i change the standards without
rework to have a safe fast and a cheap
way of the analysis for those two
nucleic acids and
for protein and of course how can I
collect my data much much faster so
there has been a big advantage in the
development of the micro fluidics
technology and the question is why
shouldn't more users like the smaller
companies and academic labs get the
advantage of what already exists and
what has been already proven to be good
since years so this is what makes me
always show the following slides what
you can see here is a comparison of two
different types of chips which has been
created and developed based on the same
technology this is a proprietary caliber
technology so the company which has
developed all his chips with calibur ii
and did happen acquired several years
ago from Burton Elmer's so today we have
license to manufacture all of these
chips types some of the participants
today might help hurts or might have
already been in touch with the
instruments which use the chips on the
left side of the flight on the beginning
the need of RNA qualifying has pushed
the development of the first generation
of microphone except for such instrument
at the bio nalizar experience so here we
call this chips to honor chips because
they are two-dimensional and they don't
have any capillary but due to need of
having in higher throughput in much more
applications a new generation of ships
have been invented this is what we call
superchips and these are all our
perkinelmer chips right now you can see
the superchips on the right side of the
slide to make a great comparison so you
have on the left side ships without the
capillary for the limited number of
samples the sample volume from next to
the other reagents so no matter whether
you have one or ten samples to run which
would be the maximum for this chip you
can use the trip only once and you lose
your thumb
go after it on the right side you have
the last generation of the trip with
three dimensional trips which allow you
to separate the reagents from the sample
plate which is very nice because you can
rerun the samples the chip is also
reusable so for example for maximum to
thousands nucleic acids or 400 proteins
additionally two disadvantages with the
superchips you're more flexible to
decide how many samples today you would
like to run you can press the trip for
example for around 50 samples leave it
in the instrument for the whole day and
then you would decide within these eight
hours humming samples you would like to
run in which order for example in the
first hour you can run 10 samples in the
second Alaric and one additional 20
samples and so on and so on so you can
also pray prep prepare another plate and
just exchange the plates with the
different types of samples so this is
where you can see some sorry about that
some benefits of the lab chip and which
have been already mentioned from the
other two presenters but I would just go
through so you have an immediate data
collection in half and immediate data
take data a copy of the office in the
software you have you can have a fast
data recall and you have a self
explaining user-friendly software you
don't have any gel smiles anymore so the
software analyzes against the lower
marker which is next to each sample you
can work safe you don't have any tedium
bromide or any other big volumes of such
substances which you could harm your
health you have a nice reproducibility a
nice resolution you're very sensitive in
where you work so you have also left
costs the samples and interestingly the
price is getting
the more samples you're running it
entities of facts but it is a point of a
different discussion so whenever you
need to not to know more about it just
let us know having mentioned the chips
and sample plates Tracy's going to start
for your video describing the chip
preparation Tracy you can go on all
reagents should be taken from storage at
4 degrees Celsius and allowed to warm at
room temperature for at least 20 minutes
before use a pipette tip attached to a
vacuum aspirator should be used during
chip preparation rinse and aspirate each
active well 1 2 3 4 7 8 9 and 10 2 times
with molecular biology grade water
aspirate from the side of each well not
from the center do not allow the active
wells to remain dry for long periods of
time after aspirating the final rinse
ensure that no droplets remain on the
sides of the chip wells use reverse
pipetting to add d steyn solution to
wells 2 and 9 using reverse pipetting to
add reagents to the chip will ensure
accurate measurement of the gel
solutions and will prevent the
introduction of bubbles use seventy five
microliters for a high-throughput chip
prep and fifty microliters for a low
throughput chip prep use reverse
pipetting to add gel dye solution to
wells three seven eight and ten add 75
microliters of gelled I two wells three
seven and eight and one hundred twenty
microliters of gel die too well 10 for a
high-throughput chip prep add fifty
microliters of gelled I two wells three
seven and eight and seventy five
microliters of gel die too well ten for
a low throughput chip prep using reverse
pipetting add marker solution from the
green capped tube too well for use one
hundred twenty microliters for a
high-throughput chip prep and fifty
microliters for a low throughput chip
prep
ensure that well one is empty and that
the top rims of the chip wells are clean
and dry before placing the chip on the
lab chip GX touch clean both sides of
the chip window with the supplied cloth
dampened with seventy percent
isopropanol ok we have seen trip
preparation coming back to the sample
preparation scheme you can see on the
left side the sample and a lot of
preparation for nucleic acids the
nucleic acid sample preparation just a
matter of transferring of the samples
with a correct linear concentration onto
96 or 384 websites for the protein
sample preparation and the samples have
to be mixed additionally with a sample
buffer which can be reducing and
non-reducing one and alternatively to be
cheat natured sizing standard so leather
have to be prepared for both of the
athletes the leather is in separated
tube and its measured after each 12
samples so this is a benefit by not
using wells on the plates and the bat
ladder runs can be recovered with good
ones with the help of the software
options you will see now the electrical
racism 14 ships this is why you will see
an additional step of disdaining so
Helius has already mentioned that and
the video is without an audio part but
the descriptions can be read trace you
can start the video
you
you
good so we're just going on as fast as
we can this is an overview of the data
analysis software a lots of
functionalities have benefits for the
users of this software so the software
is free to use and to download on our
homepage the plat plate may map on the
left side of the software is showing you
that you can upload as many place that
you want and you can compare them so you
can compare samples within one plate or
in between of many plates and as Judith
has already mentioned you have also
virtual gel so this is not a real jail
this is just just a digitalized image
created as a projection of the
electropherogram in chicken see also
pick and well tables which are
displaying a quantitative an exportable
data so you can explore the data in PDF
and ecs reform in case you have to make
the difference between how to recycle
homozygous alleles you can use this the
expected peak still in the software
analysis option where you can select
different colors for each homozygous
alleles and apply to one or two more
plates and you can see that whenever
detected this alleles which will appear
in those colors previously selected in
the analysis settings in the gel view
and in the electropherogram for the
distinguishing of the overexpressed
protein in a cell lysis for example you
could use either the expected peak or
the overlay option the example shown
here are done by overlays so just by
clicking on the control button of the
computer or by selecting of the samples
which have to be compared respectively
overlaid so the first electropherogram
is showing you the overexpressed protein
this one is showing utilize
it that one is showing you an overlay of
the sterilized it with and without the
peak of the elver expressed proteins and
the left electropherogram is showing
you're actually differently expressed
protein in the same cell lighted I'm
almost done this is just a instead of
conclusion of a conclusion this is a
list of some of the customers from
always in database and this companies
have decided to say goodbye to the flat
shells and we hope that a lots of other
users of sludge else would appear in the
slide so we could update it soon
hopefully well thank you very much for
your attention and please write us
whenever you have you would like to ask
something either in the chat or much
better by using my mail address I'm also
in LinkedIn so you can write me also
there Thank you Thank photonica another
great presentation and thanks for RAM
for all of the presenters forum for the
information that you brought us today
and so we already have a number of
questions that have come in during the
end the presentations and so I just
wanted to give you a quick reminder and
about how to reach us today and if you
have any more questions or comments and
so your questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we'll get to
them right now and hopefully answer as
many as we can so I'm so first of all
and the first question I wanted to
address with from Eric Ries at
sigma-aldrich hope I got the the the
pronunciation of your name right Eric
and but next question is and I'm
assuming that this is directed toward
Sandra and have you been able to compare
the NGS results using gel analyzed
samples versus the lab chip Sandra any
any comment on that one
and yes also the the 95 samples that we
did in the initial validation of the lab
kit we are really the only sample set
that we've got gel gel pictures for
every sample and allowed tip
concentrations on those them samples and
then they were analyzed for ten GS they
so actually you in invalidating next
generation sequencing as a whole and as
I was saying in my presentations will be
back live it we we've actually just
worked out where our cutoff points for
food plus gel intense band was and then
that he actually correlate to
concentrations of about about above one
milligram per microliter which then gave
us good India sequencing results for all
those samples we could have reported as
to what we're using today actually about
two years on those battles that we can
report that has those concentrations on
on the lab tip but fair example we don't
think then we had a real girl anymore
we've just gone from lack of
concentration of greater than one
milligram per microliter and we get good
sequencing results so hopefully that
answers your question ok thanks Sandra
and so I'm another question that we've
had is an old I like this one to them to
Veronica and this is from Drew
liechtenstein at novus International and
so is it possible to do blotting type
experiments on the system unfortunately
not directly so we can't really do
amanhã blotting with our system and to
answer may be your second question which
could come now we can't do multiplexing
with the system so we have only one
laser and one source of excitation so at
this moment this is not possible yet ok
thanks
and so I'm haha there was a question
from andreas press at the ENT clinics
and tuebingen and his question or it was
a comment under question and so
basically the comment was that it was
said that the the the lab chip
technology could be used as an
alternative to sds-page and that you can
use reduced and non-religious buffers so
in theory it seems that would be
possible to see a gel shift if proteins
interact and so all the likeness wanted
to Julius and Julius is presentation
concerned and protein analysis so I'm
the question there Julius is it is it
possible to look at them protein-protein
interactions and by looking at the gel
shift with the the lab chip technology I
mean two things what what what you said
if should be reduced and non reduce okay
then you you can look at that if they
interact with a sort of bridges so this
you you will see probably but because
you cook the sample and you still in
this case it's as we using it there is
SDS you just destroy an interaction that
will exist except of covalent
interaction which are in this case or
visit sustain formulas of two bridges
which you can you can possibly see
whether there is I think we ask for
glamour and I think there is not at the
moment edge was really great to have a
native electrophorus is where you just
don't have any any sds-page and run it
without now that will be really
interesting although although although
again you still need some charge to
separate you know it will be more like
like like really gel filtration thing
which which you can do one and that but
again you will for the native to the
protein my great space on the charges
I'm not sure whether this this is
possible with this pacifier now not now
but now now maybe in the past it would
become something like that it will be
really nice because it will be in a
small scale it will be very great
okay so I think I'm Julius boy thing is
that you don't know for sure but it's
you know you it's a possibility I don't
don't think so it's dairy I don't think
that is it possible I mean if you go
with a native protein you cannot run
them so you need to really cook down in
a present of of SDS or anything crafty
cook them the interaction destroyed so
the only which you can really see it if
this is termination or in kind of
organization or abiding food assistance
which will be then reducing and
non-reducing condition to run separately
okay okay great thanks Julia and I think
that's clear and I'm going to direct
another question to the Julius if you
don't mind and this is from montserrat
serra at the IRB and and mantras and
comment is that I used to work with
membrane proteins in detergent myself
they run very noisy and in sds-page gel
when the detergent is high and with
these samples and run any better with
the lab chip technology do is based on
your experience answer it you need to
try that that I think we know the
complex sample like like like when you
have crude extra against wall when
you're trying another lots of stool
membrane left and Tamia some detergent
in life it's it's it's possible but even
in sds-page you utilities fattiness
they're here advantages maybe the
sensitivity as you go with load and
master sample and you can see much
better probably loading glass and
diluting the detergent and everything it
could be allowing you to to see a better
resolution she's better but I would say
this will depend from the sample to
sample more or less so our just give it
try there is icing option okay great
thanks Jules and I'm going to listen
please do wrong please do yeah because
I'm
when we say it's worth a try I would
like to mention that we have a demo
laboratory in Frankfurt where we usually
get so we have them contact with
potential users of the GX who interested
on testing some samples so we're never
interested in our system you can contact
us and we could organize the testing of
the samples in Frankfurt ok thanks
Veronica and so on I'm going to direct
the next question to Sandra and and the
question is can you comment on how the
running costs compared between the M
that the gels that you previously run
which which I'm assuming Sandra of
acrylamide based gels and can you
compare those costs to the end that the
running costs with your current lab chip
approach and I huh specifically compare
the cost it's a bit in amazing terms in
terms of our department because we've
actually changed our our workflow from
what we were doing so so now we run
every samples as we need that
quantitation data for our next
generation sequencing the cost would be
more because before as I mentioned we
were only running the controls or
something just to check that out our pcr
has worked and then we were going ahead
and doing doing the rest of the
sequencing so so now we went the
opposite way where we analyze everything
on the logic and then we work to save
money by by eliminating any samples that
have failed at any point in reaction we
don't send them on to downstream
sequencing processes which i think is a
big is it because saving for department
because it's it is expensive technology
so yes specifically I can see a question
with actual numbers however yeah that's
that's where we are and of course mate
labor we're with you becomes now and
just lose the play it will tighten sees
things maybe 10-15 minutes to load the
chips loads of play on and then they can
run that trip all all day for
444 fourth consecutive full plate so
compared to two actually the labor of
yelling that many samples would would be
a lot let's get only issue maybe a big
number okay I mean certainly and I think
her experience in / kilometers that it
really depends on first of all the type
of gel that you're actually using and
but also the number of samples that
you're doing and so I'm I know that
there are different manufacturers of
them of precast gels and if you're
running you know anywhere above sort of
48 sample the day and the costs per
sample and tend to be around about the
same and for a sort of median priced
swab gel and for nucleic acids so and
i'm going to hand over another question
to a to julius and this is another
another question from andreas breath at
the end ENT clinics and health question
is regarding what the resolution is like
for really large proteins and give the
example of that titan TN yeah I tyken
it's a really bad example no I mean the
huge protein so I think no one will ever
be able maybe to be fun and I mean c5000
and it's really huge so the problem the
problem or the limitation I think of the
chip is that you have this this range
from 14 kilo 2 200 maximum these
proteins around 200 kilo Dalton I think
that's the limit I'm sure whether one
can put something much bigger as a
tightness it's 85 thousand it is really
huge there I think we're running the
biggest biggest proud in which we had
was hundred hundred kilo dalton and i
think this was resolved quite quite nice
it depends i think probably on the gel
matrix i think it could be that one can
make something that can be has a higher
higher actually types of the protein
it's not that the moment at the market I
think okay thanks thanks Julius and so I
think we'll take one more question
before we em before we finish and Sandra
and Julius who pees or tea or what used
to pay for the disposal costs for use
gels in your lab and by that I think
what is meant is them you know is this
something there's a cost in the case of
Julius for example and that you know
does your individual lab and actually
take the cost of gel disposal or is that
sort of you know is that cause born by c
the university and higher level and
symbols never said that said actually in
our case the course of course golf order
for the main main a kind of vista to dem
fpl so they are but it's a cost which
you still need to think on either you
you paid your from your budget or you
paid as a kind of university it's the
same call it is still the cost for the
toxic waste so it's a special way they
need to go and and then there is charge
on the amount of big pot with your kind
of we call it black pot where all these
things go so you you you need to take in
content as well that is using using lab
gb or you're saving and so it's a safety
risk and actually actually it's decrease
the cost finally that's Ted clear and so
it should use it and if if you just
clarify that last point I mean what I
mean what what sort of them have you
noticed in terms of them costs when you
move to the lab chip approach compared
to the other disposal costs on jail oh I
think I I I completely agree here with
series ah completely forgot ah it's very
sorry more you're on it cheaper it on
and that that's why it's good to run
several samples at once and to run
mortgage is then the prices we're going
to
we were doing some surgery the beginning
trying to compare them and it was I
think almost the same at the beginning a
44 well pair of pecan shells and
actually the the well in the artist
surrounding the sample on the left you
but again if you take into account all
these staining these paintings which are
not there and kind of in a work which
you have to secular I need to now scan
the gels and make quantification and all
these things you know justice as well
work of two people who are you to pay it
is going definitely a lower and and it
starts to pace pace off but then it's
some kind of number of the samples which
was good to run per day that added that
it really is the same or it's just for
now okay thank you yes and Sandra any
comments on disposal costs you know and
you know any sort of idea of how
disposal costs changed but you know
between you being running gels racism
the lab champ I again really and I'm not
sure the specific so that we actually
used to make our own evolution of gel so
at very percentages this from from the
powder base and dilute it down and add
the most minimal amount of a city and
bromide we possibly push through our
girls will just load up this explosive
just in the general clinical waste which
I actually can't comment on whether
that's the department costs or like a
bigger Health Department costs so yeah
get help you with that okay thanks so
we've run a little bit over and and so I
think we're going to close there and I
just like to thank again Sandra Doran
and dr. Julius Causton and Veronica del
fever further for the presentations and
and if there are no comments and from
any of the speakers or anyone else and
I'm just going to say you know goodbye
to everyone and again just to thank our
speakers
and response a perkin-elmer for making
it possible to bring this presentation
to you so I'm so thanks everyone for
listening and the the web seminar will
be available for on-demand viewing and
throughout me or all the way through
until me 2016 and you will receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and post them on Rob
routes comm you're welcome of course to
forward this announcement to any
colleagues who aren't able to join in
today and so thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast and
we'll see you next time thank you very
much